Facebook's vested interest is it for it
to work for advertisers and the people
that consume it it's the only currency
they have television has Nielsen's
that's fake Facebook's an amazing
product because it's kind of like Vayner
the only reason we're a good agency is
because I want to become the brand's and
thus the collateral of my mission is
we're good with clients not maximizing
our I would sell programmatic and
television if I want to make money I
[Music]
give without expectation knowing that
karma and good is smart and will work if
we even need it the most pure testing
environment to me right now is Facebook
if you're going to want these five and
up your there they're at scale
what is 13 up for sure it's crazy all
these companies that do research and
insights right 500 thousand they survey
like hey ma'am at Albertson's hey ma'am
do you want to go in this room it's all
contacts not contact everyone so
addicted to the content the contents
number two it's the context I just
yelled that Sid he's like hit me up for
swipe Abed he's like just make a generic
one I'm like why I'm right here I'm
gonna say no hey India hey Brazil hey
next to the context is the ROI that was
that black bean that's gonna honestly
that's gonna work but it's gonna convert
better that's the punchline like the
puns like that's the thing like you guys
have me well the beauty with me is like
Brazil what is up you're not following
my content enough swipe up if you want
to win an entrepreneurship because the
dynamics that I believe in over-index in
South America more than even here in New
York then hubris I mean it's context did
you get yelled at did you take it like a
man
a quick question yeah we have pretty
good relationships with Amazon nobody
has a relationship with Amazon is there
any value in the concept of doing an
exclusive thing with them nope you
should do an exclusive thing on you're
calm and use Amazon we need the [ __ ]
Amazon before it [ __ ] us
[Music]
hey it's Carrie dunes and how are you
are you very good thanks for the
interest Baseball said you're gonna
consume us the way we baseball want not
the way you want I couldn't be more down
on baseball 35 years from now based on
what they're doing now kids are not
growing up with baseball cards like they
did there's new alternatives like
everyone's like well it's a great summer
night well guess what you know what
every eight to 13 year old in America is
doing on summer nights right now they're
staying inside and playing for night
boxing and horse racing where the most
popular sports along with baseball in
this country in nineteen twenty thirty
and forty and guess what now we're in a
digital world and that's who's gonna
benefit aka eSports a.k things like the
NBA that understand how to manipulate it
and you know who's gonna lose baseball
third-tier NBA players are getting
famous and the biggest superstars of
baseball are completely and utterly not
known I have a funny feeling if Major
League Baseball had a culture where a 41
year old catcher could make $300,000 off
the field because he's a personality
that you would see things change
systematically baseball is very good at
not taking on accountability it's time
it does and they better move quickly
because very quickly people are gonna be
watching video game players throw swords
at each other instead of baseballs and
hitting with bats very quickly it's
nothing it's already happened
now it's can they start the process of
unwinding it
because the Dania the days of baseball
cards in your bike spokes are over
they're not reinvesting in their
business they're sucking it dry and they
will pay the price period and the story
period and the story every other
conversation is the micro and is
fundamentally irrelevant to the actual
thing that's happening that's a lesson
for everybody in everything in life
[Music]